Even if a movie follows skilled sword fighters,
warriors, or martial arts experts, it's still
actors who need to play out the scenes. And
as good as fight choreography might be, mistakes
are bound to happen. And the bigger the budget
or drama, the funnier those slip ups become.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Movie Mistakes That
Slipped Through Editing FIGHTS EDITION.
Terminator 2
By the time this sequel was released, everyone
knew the skills and strengths of the T-800.
But the opening barfight for Arnold's character
put the mythology - and the props - to the
test. A small knife can barely do any damage
because of the metal skeleton underneath his
skin, but seeing the rubber stunt knife completely
bend and deform proves that steel isn't the
only factor at work.
If Zack Snyder knows one thing, it's a speed-ramp
filled action sequence. The Spartans showed
they were more terrifying than any other soldier
by breaking ranks to slash, stab, kick, punch,
and spear their oncoming enemies. But it may
not have been as hard as it sounds. When the
Spartan king throws a spear into the chest
of a Persian, the soldier next to him is sent
flying. Whether it's sympathy impact, or just
looking for an excuse to get out of the battle,
we'll never know.
The Matrix
The Wachowskis' idea of "bullet time" changed
action movies forever, but when they weren't
inventing new types of action, they were copying
plenty others - like the wire work of Eastern
martial arts movies. Every fan knows that
Keanu Reeves couldn'treallybackflip a
dozen feet in the air out of the way of a
subway train. But when you watch the actor's
hands, and realize he's holding onto the wires
pulling him up the entire time, you might
wonder why the directors didn't even bother
to hide the giveaway, or ask for another take.
The Dark Knight Rises
Bane's henchmen don't get too much attention
in the final chapter of Christian Bale's Batman,
but a few nameless stuntmen do end up earning
the spotlight - for the worst possible reason.
There's the highly-trained League assassin
who falls for absolutely no reason during
a rooftop fight with Batman and Catwoman.
But that's not the worst fight scene mistake
in the movie: that honor goes to the other
League gunman who decides to just pretend
he's been hit, despite nobody even coming
near him. It may have been his best option.
Star Wars: Revenge of The Sith
When most of what's seen on screen is created
in a computer, you would think that mistakes
would be easy to hide or avoid. But what happens
when Jedi start fighting hand-to-hand, or
foot-to-foot, and the actors can't sell the
moves? Anakin's running kick during his showdown
with Obi-wan is a rough enough stunt, since
Ewan McGregor reacts before the kick even
lands. But the move that immediately follows
it is.... well, the less said about it the
better.
Mr. and Mrs. Smith
This movie might be most famous for uniting
one of Hollywood's biggest couples, but the
fight scene between Brad Pitt and Angelina
Jolie is anything but forgettable. Buried
between the punches and kicks, there's even
a scene played for laughs, when the pair's
battle sends a couch shaking and jumping on
the floor of their house. Don't bother asking
how it's done, either - you can clearly see
the crew member shaking the couch when he
pops into frame.
Fast Five
There's no point in poking holes in the physics
or realism of the Fast & Furious series, but
that doesn't mean they don't make SOME mistakes
worth catching. When the crew steal a vault
in the fifth installment, the police they're
stealing from take exception. The first officer
to investigate gets a surprise hello from
The Rock, dropping him with a single punch.
It's hard to say if it was the actor or the
character who wanted to go easy on the cop,
but the boxing glove taking him out was a
nice gesture all the same.
Transformers: Age of Extinction
There are too many continuity errors to count
in the Transformers series, assuming audiences
are looking for them. But there's one that
is more obvious, more baffling, and more worrying
than any other. When star Mark Wahlberg is
heading to take out the movie's transforming
villain, he takes cover behind a stone wall,
moments before it's blown to pieces. But the
man who suddenly appears just in time to be
killed is never explained. If you've got a
theory, we're all ears.
Gladiator
Everyone knows that Ridley Scott's Gladiator
epic is filled with small mistakes or fake
attacks, but it's the stranger, less expected
mistakes that are the most fun to spot. During
the reenactment of the Battle of Carthage,
there's a good chance that audiences will
be too distracted by seeing an archer sliced
in half to notice the chariot supervisor tucked
away on board. But his black clothing and
work boots are hard to miss, once you've spotted
them.
Return of The Jedi
We covered this one in our other video “10
Hilarious Details Hidden In The Backgrounds
Of Movies” but it’s just too amazing to
leave out! In Star Wars Episode 6 Return Of
The Jedi, when Luke is battling Jabba’s
goons on a ship near the Sarlacc Pit, he is
seen kicking one of them in the face. The
fast movements almost hide the mistake but
if you slow down the sequence, it’s obvious
Luke was nowhere near the stuntman’s face…
Or was it a Force Kick?! I guess we’ll never
know…
Those are the mistakes, blown punches, kicks,
and overall errors we found in our favorite
fight scenes, but which ones did we miss?
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more Movie
Mistakes Videos Like this one!